Stop a Papa welcome back everybody I should not be singing to another wonderful oh
We uncovered some dark secrets about our parents their house doesn't have any
Blood in it. Why don't we loot all this ah?!
Lot of client, that's good. You know I'm gonna keep looting
Something's up with our parents. We don't really know what yet I suspect that they have been putting fart juice in our food
Which has actually been helping us all alone.
But something is definitely oh
You could you could say that again. That's my
Jimmy impression or Timmy they all have the same names, let's get real here
An
attack on the SP PD police station last night has left citizens in shock and disbelief
with prisoners now on the loose and policemen in the
Hospital one member of the Chamber of Commerce has had enough and is announcing his bid for mayor
Go around voting on people dead together
We can free ourselves from the anal terrorism that has been forced upon us my name is Mitch Conner
Oh, and I enjoyed it. Is that a transgender hand
Going into politics
Because I mean it's 2017 and I'm not really surprised, but at the same time just wanted to make sure mitch is okay
You know what my god. I can never do this bit. I did it. I don't have a thing. Oh wow oh
Tom's feel like you have no idea what to do next you
Haven't been given any direction, and you're unsure. What's even going on
And no not without it's because you've been trying to find yourself in the wrong way
Knowing your sexual identity or race or ethnicity that's nothing compared to knowing who you are
spiritual hairiness
Go to the pod. Okay. Someone is waiting for you at the pond who will finally help you find your true self
It's gonna be more pedophiles isn't it well?
Let's do the side quest it seems like the game is telling us to do the side quest and I want to know who I
am as
spiritually obviously
Christian or Swiss chin as I like to call it Swedish Christian. Thank you very much um
I'm surprised. We haven't done it before I thought we were gonna do it like early in the game because you were
Deciding what kind of character you wanted to make I think we might use one of the teammate stations
It's jimothy I keep forgetting is pleading name all right. This is the pond
Okay, we can go there
It's the pond where the first game ends in where we throw the stick of truth in
spoilers a
spoiler alert
It's a big piece of the plot
Just like there you go, there you go, buddy
We getting a lot of questions about my invisible headphones, they're not for sale
You can't get it look you I'm gonna play with fire - hey, man where's Jasper
He's in trouble good talk what in the world another fast travel, okay? That's good
We have to walk all the way Oh
Get over here. Yes. Yes, yes, yes, what's up? I?
Believe we can help each other okay? Have you heard of the super best friends? Well it is I?
a
Powerful superhero with the amazing ability to talk to fish and swim its
Seamen that see man. It is my job to help all creatures of the sea and right now
There is a gay fish who wants help getting his mother its Oh
No all the other super best friends keep saying they're too busy, will you help?
Yes, of course then swim down to the water's depth with me. Don't worry my water defenses shall protect you
He's gonna drown us isn't he the new kid dives down through the water protected by seamen. Oh my god
I like a support made fun of cement before seamen before oh my god
It's Eman and yes, I do this child has incredible powers all right if you get my mom into heaven
I will give you three million dollars and some jewelry just touch my little gay flipper
and we shall be magically transported to help her I
Thought Kanye West would be in it for a minute
So seaman sidekick had to help the gay fishes mum fly to heaven on a stream of rainbow unicorn we're playing flappy birds oh
My god we're playing flappy bird. This is 10 times better however
Oh, I can't go too high
This is kind of nice honestly I
Hope not oh wow it's going it's going real fast you're going so fast
All they move now I
Don't want to mess up
Natsu
Oh
No
And so Lehman sidekick has to help the gay fishes mom fly to heaven on a stream of rainbow unicorn oh my god
oh
I see it's app isn't it a parody of it's a parody of Kanye West's game
How did I not hit me oh?
That's brilliant. He's making a game about his mom going to heaven
All the gays fishes mom of course
It all makes sense
How do I dodge this I am, but he's shooting me with fucking flame, are you serious oh?
Thank thank thank you game Thank You game. That's quite enough. I get it. Thank you
Did I do it my god, what a skill I take
So it is Kanye West
What is that?
It's James add on very well by John grace JQ. Yeah. No not you seamen the kid hey man
Oh, yeah, right?
anyway
You had no reason to help this little gay fish my child and yet you did that's right every reason to help me
I'm a lyrical genius voice of a generation
I see that you were trying to determine your spirituality my child
Allow me to help thee there are good and bad in every religion my child which are you?
Rastafari Satan Scientologist seek Unitarian
Christian Chris, okay, you're a chaotic Christian. That's me
Finally
You want a selfie with Jesus right of course Jesus
Thank you for making. It less awkward for mailed you know who you are now
You are one step closer to believing in yourself my God. Thank you Jesus hashtag blessed
That was amazing I love the side quests in this game every time. They show up
Chaotic Christian
Chaotic Racine Scandinavian
That's me dank leaders. Why are you talking like that?
dialogue tree
Got you. We don't take kindly to your types around here. Let's welcome this fan to our town
They triggered imprinted
Welcome nugget
Alright, let's just kill these guys really quick. I don't we've done it like four times. I don't think there's that much to see
Okay, we dealt with that we chose a religion chaotic Christian I
Love this like I said, I want to do more side quests. It's definitely worth it
I know your mind blown now that we're friends on the grams in real life, but keep it cool. Oh, right
I almost got hit by them. He's in trouble. Maybe we should tell his parents or something dude
He probably just found some porn anyway Jesus called, but he needs to respect artistry
This social media platform does not respect artists don't talk to me then impose game. Oh, she's back
Where's the camera set up there
Thank you classy
Can't wait to use that okay, well let's go to the what would they call friends?
Freedom fighters whatever whatever they are freedom palace, that's it freedom fires has said it's too obvious
Well it's in this great
I
Wonder who
Wonder
This was someone who wanted to hurt us yes
It was an image
I didn't exactly and I say new kid or you will never see your parents again, and hurry or else. They'll be more
No stop it it is too much. Where is who you man, catch the new kids
You took the new kids parents because you hate that we merged with Freedom House, that's not true
I want this mega franchise more than anybody tell him dad
You have five seconds Cartman I'm on your side, yo kid you believe me, don't you?
Oh, Timmy, how are you gonna get update? Oh, No?
Ah thanks Timmy you
Wait what what Timmy Timmy Timmy No are you serious right now
I can you tell him it to me that I can use any oh my god
That one's really good that one's really good
That one's okay. Oh my god this changes the game
Yeah, no you said it before and it's kind of awkward every time
Okay, let's keep going
We have all the classes now in our back story is complete. We saw our parents
having sex
No wait we saw our dad talking her man
Have you guys ever walked in you know? What don't answer that?
Luckily never happened to me
Go to the place where people get their copy figs better hurry tick tock tick tock snake attack
If it did happen I probably blocked it out of my memory. I know it was left and right well
There's only those ways to go isn't it I know it's closed. It's what I'm trying to say
Should be quiet, please
Is the inside probably?
Yes
I don't know if you're a hero or a menace man this coffee really has me buzzed
Hello
It's for you. Oh, wow. That's real good new kid, but now I'm gonna make things a little harder on you
Okay, telling you where to go. I'm giving you a riddle you ready yes a place
Where death comes in all shapes and sizes go into this door to find what your prize is Oh Maggie dear?
I'm so wasted on this stuff
That riddle
It's impossible oh no not the shitting in yes
I do think yes, I do
You have made many enemies in this town vigilante and now you have to face
That he took our jobs that was no not crappy, but now you go cross the line
This should be interesting damn
Wish I had a titty mag oh damn look at that damaged dog ah damn boy
It wasn't that interesting actually
Haha, sorry is normal battle. I don't think you guys need to see everything as solve Connors death store riddle now
Where could that possibly be?
Hey, thanks for being the only one who believed me of course why would I not believe oh?
my god
For now just do what he says suspicious I
Can't fast travel anymore I
think the abortion center
Which is a lovely place to go and last time we went there
It was weird I still remember that from the first game my god every time. I close my eyes. I just
Imprinted in my retina
No, no thank you, thank you, we're almost there Oh
Any time now that's a rhino place. Where's the abortion clinic then?
unplanned Parenthood I
Don't listen to her okay, that's not true
Excuse me
excuse me while I
This is where I need to be we got some new stock. Which is a rare treat with our funding
Have a fabulous day. You want to feel the baby kick that sorry kind of interrupting a tender moment here kid I?
suppose not
Well then I don't know
God damn it no no
Sure you don't understand it. How could you?
What's the gay face doing they say that's my great challenge
That's the weight on my shoulders to bring understanding to the people you understand. Well I
But how could you you're working from an old model?
I'm an original
You know artists come up to me all the time
And already you get inspiration and that's all wrong because I don't get inspiration I always had it I popped
I was in game bitch day one
Original and gay fish is something that can't be changed because it's inside me and all around me. It's like air or water
But see I ain't scared because I know tomorrow I will be motherfuckin game bitch immutable
This just seems like a nice life
Yeah, she hit some columns we all hit some columns and
Columns on the way up to heaven on a motherfucking unicorn
I didn't see anybody else's mama riding the unicorn to heaven while we was up there. Did you know because that was some original?
Shit in conclusion. That's why you gotta let gay fish
Okay like some kind of weapons yeah, we're here
Not really that you see the guy standing over there take a selfie with him do it now your mom is gonna suffer
Someone's calling me
Sorry it's not a game vigilante you're gonna get somebody killed, but let's take a selfie anyway
You're gonna have to stop one more riddle and the place where seats hang from chains part desert part jungle where happiness reign
Wait there's another riddle
Oh my god, thank you
This is all Connor supporters
Oh my god, why
Cm ham kid oh that was it okay?
The community center, where is that?
God damn boy when who is the community center?
Here we are at the community center
Alright one two I feel like there's gonna be some pot with that. It is actually a nice Cartman. Oh my god
What have you done with the new kids parents badass nothing yet, but when I'm finished with you
I can't say they'll be exactly safe this has gone far enough. We end it now the only thing about the end is you mysterious
What this is like a
Smash man we're actually fighting Mitch Conner, okay?
So your parents got kidnapped, but no I can totally relate as a kidnapped victim myself all right funny, okay?
I can't actually reach him from here
No
Damn it
Alright, let's just sit our turn
Damn yes a lot of healthy
Then who did it
Is he not there, I can't see this is another weird thing like I can't go over there. I can't see
Whatever I'll just stop here
My muscular body
This must be like to freight at stage bias because it otherwise is too easy oh
Okay, guess what oh?
My god. He has a fart ability
Yes of course of course it's Connor Cartman I believe II we can use
Even the new kid and turn his back on you teen
Wow pretty up Oh guys, I'm not that will decrease your movement dude. Oh, No
Nice it's pretty easy uh-oh he's on fire nevermind
Okay alright, okay, okay, no be quiet
You seem to be taking all the damage
after further calculations that damage didn't happen
What?
Activate again what?
All right, we need a good damage hold, I don't know if Craig has it yeah. He does oh, man. That's really good. Oh
Yeah, yes the little hamster. Love it. It's so cute. It's the best one
You're only hurting yourself oh
Whoa what the hell it's gonna sting damn
He's strong man. He ricochetted my damn it
What you get to mix up dan I
Take it back man. He's really strong no stop come on, No
I
Swear to God if he says that doesn't count
Come on Jesus, thank you. This is really tricky, man. I almost messed up even pathetic
Yeah, I'm chill great now she skips a turn great
So make me hella anxious yes, I said hella, that's how much you make it okay, all right?
Let me just kill him I want to counter them
Police police work, yes. Oh that feels good finally
He's dead right no no no. Thank you
What's gonna happen at
You never knew oh no he's got
Its muscular yeah, sometimes torture is the only answer you're gonna torture me for what everyone get back to Freedom House base
We have to make this shithead talk. What are you talking about guys? It's me the key?
They played him like a damn fiddle
I'm on I'm literally here. I'm literally outside. Okay. Let's get in very
nice
Sounds they got here very nice
merriness a
Very a nurse
Okay, let's see what this is this is a but. It's wrong with you guys. I'm not your enemy
You're going to talk Cartman new kid you're going to have to make Cartman talk
Are you gonna do it. Oh my god, he's gonna fart in his face
You guys are wasting your time. I'm the king torture doesn't work against me remember. That's true. He doesn't
Watch you eat is that it? I'm not afraid
The burrito of course
He hate the aluminum foil as well
I'm pressing part you will tower Cartman. I will eat the broccoli name
The octopus
Hit him again
Ah
Yes
What cats I just remembered
The fries jog my memory
Said he must he was what to genetically alter the cats the genetics laugh doctor mephesto. Yes, that must be attack yes
Alright, let's check it out in the next episode. Thank you guys so much for watching another one. I don't know
Let's do a save there, and I'll see you guys tomorrow as always it's quite a fan